(crowd applauding)
- All right everybody, let's finish up
with a heartwarming story.
I'm pretty sure you're gonna love.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
(crowd cheering and applauding)
For six years, retired California
Fire Captain Shane Porter
bonded with his sons working together
to restore a 1969 Jeepster.
It was a passion project
that came to a halt last year
when Shane passed away,
that is until a local high
school teacher volunteered
to have his class take over the project.
Now, a year later, the
Jeep looks brand new,
and Shane's family
couldn't be more grateful.
We have Shane's wife,
Tigger, on the line right now
along with Bob, the high school teacher
who took on the project.
They watch on NBC Four Los Angeles.
What's going on y'all?
(crowd cheering and applauding)
- Hey, hey.
Hi, Kelly!
- Oh my gosh, that Jeepster is so cool.
So, Bob, how did this all start?
- Well, everyone knows
the Porter family in town.
They're an amazing family,
and they do so much for their community
and so much for the school district,
and I've known them for years.
When Shane passed away, I was
helping Tigger at the house,
saw the Jeepster in the garage,
and she told me about
the restoration project.
I'm an automotive technology instructor,
and I came back to my class,
talked to my advanced class,
and they said, we have to
do this for the family.
It was not even a question.
We did a 15-month restoration on it,
and when we gave it back to the family,
it was a very emotional day,
and there wasn't a dry eye in the house.
- Oh my gosh, what a special
class of kids you got.
That's amazing, and Tigger,
what a beautiful surprise for you, right?
- Oh, yes, yes.
You know what?
These kids had no idea
who I was, what we did,
what, you know, I'm a paramedic,
and they have no idea, you
know, anything about us,
but they did this out of
the kindness of their heart,
and they did this because
of Bobby's teaching.
My boys are gone now.
My oldest is in the Air Force,
and my youngest is in the Army, and Shane.
So, I'm alone now.
So, when I need it the most,
I just get in the Jeep,
and I drive, and it's like
we're all together again.
(crowd sighing)
(crowd cheering and applauding)
- I mean, I love that
life works out like that,
and by the way, thank you so much.
Please tell your sons thank
you so much for their service,
first of all.
(crowd cheering and applauding)
Now, you have this beautiful reminder.
Every time you get in this
vehicle, like they're still
with you in some way.
Bob, thank you so much for being
such an incredible teacher.
First of all, teachers
make the world go 'round.
So, thank you for that.
(crowd cheering and applauding)
Your class is incredible.
Tigger, you probably look
so badass in that Jeepster.
I'm not kidding, girl,
you probably look so fly
driving around in that.
I'm like, I'm not only liking,
I'm loving your post right
now, guys, all right?
(post dinging)
- [Tigger] Oh.
- [Bob] Thank you.
- [Tigger] Thank you, thank you.
- And that's not all.
Our season-long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of friXion, the go-to erasable pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to celebrate teachers, like Bob,
instilling such kindness
and thoughtfulness
into his students.
So, they are giving
Bob a thousand dollars.
(crowd cheering and applauding)
Just for being amazing.
- Oh my gosh!
- Yeah!
That's so cool!
- Thank you guys so much!
Beautiful, beautiful people.
Thank you for joining us.
Thank you to all our guests this hour.
Josh Gad, Andrew Rannells,
Davido, and Nicole Avant.
Y'all have a great day, and if it's not,
try and change it.